do you know what was the fastest growing
stock of the last decade some of the
most common guesses would be apple
google amazon and facebook those of you
who are more involved in the markets
might guess something like nvidia amd or
netflix and those of you trying to cheat
using the title would guess dominos but
you'd actually be wrong because the
number one performing non-penny stock
was some company called neurocrine
biosciences but number two was indeed
domino's which produced a whopping
fifty three percent 3753 throughout the
2010s
that's three times amazon over four
times apple and over 11 times google
so here's how dominos squashed all the
tech giants and became the second
fastest growing stock of the 2010s
taking a look back at the late 2000s
domino's was already one of the largest
pizza chains in the world
but they didn't particularly have a good
reputation people actually hated their
pizza the reason they were able to grow
so big was because of their insane
convenience and speed throughout the
1980s dominoes introduced one of the
most infamous marketing campaigns in
food delivery history they promised that
if they couldn't deliver your pizza in
30 minutes it was free
given that a significant portion of the
pizza buying market was just broke
college students and young adults this
was extremely attractive sure the pizza
might suck but you had a chance of
getting it for free
unfortunately this promise put delivery
drivers under a lot of pressure and
domino's would end the campaign after
the death of 20 delivery drivers despite
the negative press they received for
putting delivery drivers under so much
stress dominoes basically became
synonymous with the fast deliveries and
convenience and this was really the
secret behind their success
but as other pizza chains like pizza
huts started to catch up to dominos by
embracing phone orders and offering
rapid delivery themselves the appeal of
dominoes fell off a cliff like i said
people hated their pizza and you can't
really overstate this
in fact dominos ran a consumer taste
test and found that people straight up
liked pizza less when they knew it was
from domino's so yeah it was bad and
with the competition on the rise
domino's had to do something this is
around the time that a man named j
patrick doyle would be promoted to ceo
of a domino's patrick had been an
executive at domino since 1997 and he
witnessed the internal downfall of
domino's first hand
on paper domino's was doing just fine
with their locations booming and revenue
increasing but the complaints from
customers were mounting up and it was
just a matter of time until customers
hit a breaking point which eventually
came in 2008.
as we all know when the 2008 financial
crisis rolled around basically every
single stock in the world got crushed
but most quality stocks were covered by
early 2010. the same could not be said
about domino's when the crisis started
dominoes crashed 60 which was a bit more
than normal but nothing too crazy and
then domino's crashed another 80 from
there which added up to a total of 92
percent they did recover a good amount
from there but they were still down 76
at the start of 2010. to put this in
perspective the owners of pizza hut yum
brands didn't even crash 50 at that peak
and they would reach a new all-time high
by april of 2010
so clearly there was much more to
domino's downfall than just the
recession
patrick was appointed ceo in march 2010
and with that begins insane rise of
domino's
patrick's first order of business was
addressing the criticism head-on and
being transparent he went out and
admitted that their pizza was trash
patrick released commercials that
showcased the horrendous feedback they
received from focus groups he showed the
feedback to employees chefs customers
executives and basically the entire
world
pizza where's the love
how hard bread sauce cheese fresh
ingredients doesn't feel like there's
much love in domino's pizza
domino's
pizza crust to me is like cardboard
is this hard to watch this stuff
yeah it's hard to watch
by finally acknowledging the criticism
instead of just ignoring it and bragging
about their convenience dominos was
actually able to address the problem the
top chefs at domino's got together and
worked on creating a new pizza recipe
from scratch they came up with 10
different crusts 15 different sauces and
dozens of different cheese combinations
they eventually narrowed down these
recipes and they approached the harshest
critics with their reinvented pizza the
critics of course liked the pizza when
they were confronted by the head chefs
and put in front of a camera but dominos
wanted to make it clear that they
weren't just looking for biased positive
feedback so they went ahead and opened a
pizza review tracker in times square
the review tracker constantly displayed
both good and bad reviews left by
customers
all this transparency motivated many
customers to give domino's another shot
and given that the pizza was actually
good now customers started to respond
positively to these changes who would
have thought that making good pizza
would have resulted in more happy
customers
anyway moving on to patrick's next
strategy we have streamlining the
domino's experience
as we discussed at the beginning the
thing that made dominos popular in the
first place was their insane convenience
and speed
dominoes had always specified that they
weren't just a pizza company but that
they were a pizza delivery company and
now that domino's was making likable
pizza they could return to their roots
the first step in regaining their
convenience lead was creating a single
point of sale system
in the early 2000s franchise owners had
the option to either use domino's sales
system or to create their own point of
sale system all franchises strongly
recommended that franchise owners use
their company's systems but it was
standard to leave the final decision up
to the franchise owners dominos however
went against the grain and forced all
franchise owners to use the domino
system many franchise owners would
actually sue dominos but domino's would
end up winning in court though this was
a controversial move at the beginning
the centralized point of sale system
streamlined domino's international
experience
aside from streamlining their customer
experience dominoes also streamlined the
dope production process
instead of making the dough at each
domino's location domino's has a set of
18 door factories across the us that
supply the 6000 stores
this may not sound like a big deal but
this system has allowed dominoes to
achieve unthinkable economies of skill
and it's actually one of their crown
jewels
anyway moving away from streamlining
production and delivery we have the
early embracement of technology
after the release of the iphone dominoes
was actually the first pizza company to
introduce a mobile ordering system
people could order it from the comfort
of their couches and more importantly
they didn't even have to talk to someone
with how antisocial our generation is
nowadays this was a game changer
dominoes also gamified the entire
process as much as possible when you
added toppings you were able to visually
see them pop up on your virtual pizza
and you could track the progress of your
pizza throughout the entire cooking and
delivery process
again with shortening attention spans
and growing impatience being able to
track your pizza live was a genius idea
domino's didn't just stop right there
either patrick embraced every
technological development he could one
of these opportunities was drone
delivery starting in 2013 dominos began
developing drone deliveries and they
would end up making the world's first
pizza drone delivery in november of
2016.
this never really caught on and i don't
think the faa was big fans of the
project but dom knows was nonetheless
trying every avenue possible to speed up
delivery another such project is
domino's self-driving car project
initially domino's was trying to modify
a traditional ford vehicle into a
self-driving car and they actually
launched it back in 2017. there was
always a safety driver though but
recently domino's has been testing a new
self-driving car from a robotics company
called neuro that doesn't have a safety
driver
maybe this will end up saving dom knows
a lot of money but we'll just have to
wait and see
speaking of making money we have
patrick's third strategy which was
increasing franchisee profits
though franchises are quite popular
franchise owners don't actually make
that much money in most cases it's the
franchises themselves that are pulling
in the majority of their profits with
all their fees and extremely low costs
while this might sound like a great deal
for the corporate company this is
actually not the case over the long term
you'll see when your franchise owners
aren't making that much money you're
probably attracting low quality
franchise owners
in 2008 the average domino's franchise
owner was only making 49 thousand
dollars per year
that's not a bad amount but there's so
many easier ways to make 49 000 per year
that don't involve operating an entire
domino's location
patrick was well aware of this so
instead of expanding the chain as fast
as possible and charging higher fees
patrick focused on increasing the profit
per store
between 2006 and 2013 dominar's location
growth was quite small averaging just
four percent per year
by not rapidly increasing the number of
stores patrick was able to focus all the
increased traffic from domino's growth
into the existing locations which
significantly increased the profit per
store by 2016 the average franchise
owner was pulling in 133 000 per year
now that's still only about half of what
you would expect from opening a
chick-fil-a location but that's still a
19-day difference from 49 000
this substantial increase in profits
attracted much higher quality franchise
owners and owners were much more open to
invest into the stores this allowed
dominos to convince many more owners to
remodel their locations into something
called the pizza theater model which was
designed to boost pickup order customers
by implementing all of these changes
patrick was able to increase domino's
profits from a low of 37 million dollars
in 2007 to 343 million dollars in 2018.
that same year patrick actually retired
from domino's after giving the company
another life
after leaving domino's patrick took a
year off before joining a mid-sized
private equity firm called the karla
group and he's been working there ever
since
as for domino's rich allison the former
president of domino's took over as ceo
and it doesn't look like growth is
slowing down anytime soon since patrick
left domino's stock is almost up another
100 percent and that's how domino
squashed every company you can think of
who knew a pizza chain would outperform
the tech giants
which pizza chain do you guys think
offers the best pizza comment that down
below
also drop a like if you're glad that
domino's reinvented their pizza and of
course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]